And I think on some level,
American policy is a red herring.
The U S is 15% of global emissions.
Um,
and we're falling.
The future of climate of the world will be determined by China,
by India,
by sub Saharan Africa.
Those are carbon footprints that are growing.
China's now almost twice as big a carbon footprint as the u s and they're
building all this infrastructure outside of China that doesn't even count,
um,
in Asia,
in Africa,
you know,
the Belton road.
Do you know this project?
So basically taking the model that the US had with like the Suez Canal in the
Panama Canal and they're building the infrastructure of the developing world.
So recently they,
they loaned um,
Kenya a huge amount of money to build a new rail line,
which was again being built with Chinese workers.
They built a rail line,
um,
then they can,
you can pay back the debt.
So China is threatening to take over the entire port of Mombasa as debt
repayment.
And this is like going on all around the world.
Highways across Africa,
across Asia are being built by Chinese workers as an in an effort to build a
new,
an imperial infrastructure for themselves.
And is the thought that they're doing this in terms of setting up the debt in a
way that's unpayable so that they could take over.
I,
that's one motive.
I think that the Kenya exam,
but they'd be happy if the deck get repaid.
I think it's,
they're,
they're stitching together an alternative to the western infrastructure of trade
and transit.
They're basically stitching together an entire second system of how the world
will work,
how the economy will work,
and it will be conducted through their own infrastructure and through their own
ports and through their own airports.
And that's being done by their own standards.
So China is now pouring more concrete,
um,
every three years than the entire,
than the u s poured in the entire 20th century.
She's crying.
If concrete were a country,
it would be the world's third biggest carbon emitter.
So the,
the,
the path of development of these other countries,
China,
India,
and sub Saharan Africa are really what's going to be writing the story of the
future.
America has a kind of,
I think like a mar moral obligation to lead because historically we had the
biggest carbon footprint.
But at the moment we're a relatively small part of the problem and within the u
s market forces are doing a lot of,
are making a lot of progress for us.
Um,
so the real issue is how do we figure out a new geopolitics that forces
countries like China to act better?
And one answer may be as weird as it is to say that,
um,
you know,
Xi Jinping is basically a dictator.
If he wants to impose new standards,
if he wants to invest aggressively in green energy,
he doesn't have any of the AHP political obstacles that we have in the u s and
so there's this sort of weird sympathy among American climate people for that,
um,
authoritarianism.
And he has,
especially since Trump has been elected,
been a lot more aggressive about talking about climate because he sees if
America's not going to be leading,
this is an opportunity for China to be like the real face of climate.
And that means they've paid,
you know,
they've invested a ton in solar and wind.
They've done a lot with air pollution.
So Beijing used to be really awful in 2013 they more than a million Chinese
people died of air pollution and now that's much better.
Um,
what have they done?
Just imposing stricter standards on,
um,
on pollution,
emissions,
coal plants,
things like that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
And um,
but you know,
we think about,
we think about carbon and the whole problem,
I think a little too much in terms of energy.
Energy is just 30% of the global carbon footprint.
And it's the easiest one to solve because wind and solar is actually really
cheap.
Now.
Most parts of the world is cheaper than dirty energy.
What's the majority of the footprint?
Well,
it's all,
nothing's a majority,
but so there's energy,
there's infrastructure,
there's transportation.
Um,
and agriculture is like a huge underappreciated part of it.
It's something like,
I don't know,
30% of the global footprint.
Um,
is it because of tractors or what does it recover?
Everything.
Everything that you need to do to run a farm.
I mean,
really everything you need to do to live in the world has some kind of carbon
footprint.
But you know,
if we were able to like feed all our cattle seaweed,
that would have like a big,
that would have a big impact.
Um,
but all kinds of crops have,
um,
have carbon footprints and they,
but they would still have to do something to get the seaweed and have the
seaweed travel the seaweed.
Yeah.
Deliver it to these farms.
Well,
you could also do,
you know,
you could imagine lab grown meat having a much smaller carbon footprint.
Um,
I mean,
it should,
if it proceeds as we expect it will.
Um,
and like I said before,
like when you look at each particular threat,
there's like,
you can see reasons for optimism.
You can see like,
oh,
we'll figure it out in this way.
We'll figure it out in that way.
But the UN says we need to have all of our global emissions by 2030 to have a
chance of averting two degrees of warming,
which they call catastrophic warming.
And the projects that we need to put into place in those 11 years are just much
bigger than I think we're capable of pulling off.
They say the UN says,
what is necessary is a global mobilization at the level of World War II against
climate starting this year,
2019 and there's just no chance to work in to do that anytime soon.
I mean,
maybe 10 years from now we'll get there.
That may even be optimistic.
Um,
but the total decarbonization that's required is we need to totally zero out on
carbon by 2050 they say.
Um,
and I just think,
you know,
a lot of these sectors are much trickier.
We could maybe zero out on energy,
zero on carbon when it comes to energy in 15 years if we wanted to.
But again,
that's just 30%.
The total problem.
Um,
which is why I think there's the negative emissions stuff.
The carbon capture is so important because it will allow us to move more slowly
than the UN says we need to.
And still if it works out,
you know,
keep the planet relatively stable,
relatively livable.
Um,
but that's,
you know,
those technologies have been called magical,
magical thinking by the Journal of Nature,
which is like the biggest scientific journal,
um,
writing about this stuff.
So it's sort of a leap of faith to think that they could solve that problem.
Do you think that we're dealing with like shifts in degrees of perception that
it,
it is things like your book,
things like Al Gore's movie,
things like,
you know,
anytime there's a new story that's written in the New York Times or in any,
any periodical,
we need more of this.
He needs to be hammered home to people that it's needs to be something that's a,
a global discussion that accelerates.
Totally.
And I think that that's happening.
You know,
I think,
um,
there was this big report that the UN did in October that spurred a lot of
conversation about it.
And I think that in a grotesque way,
the best teacher is just extreme weather.
You know,
when you see every year these California wildfires,
every year they're burning.
And that is really dramatic.
People I talked to in Europe are focused on the California fires,
even though they have wild fires over there.
There's something about the California fires that they're really worried about
when you see these global heat waves,
when you see unprecedented hurricane seasons,
we just had the typhoon in the Pacific in February,
first time in recorded history.
Um,
you know,
when every day on the news there's some,
um,
there's some,
you know,
dramatic extreme weather and when they come one after the other,
I think that's a really powerful teaching tool.
So,
you know,
there's,
this term is now outdated,
but 500 year storm,
you hear a lot about 500 year storm means,
you know,
hurricane that would hit a particular area once every five centuries,
right?
That means five centuries ago there were no white people in America.
So that means we're talking about a storm that would hump come once as colonists
came to America as they,
you know,
committed genocide against the native Americans as they built their own empire.
So they built an empire of slaves and cotton as they fought a civil war.
They fought world war one's,
they fought World War II.
Everything that we've done would expect one,
one storm of that kind.
In that time,
hurricane Harvey was the third 500 year storm to hit Houston in three years.
We are living in such unprecedented climate that it's impossible to look at the
news and not learn that despite all of our inclinations,
all of our reflexes to look away,
I think it is seeping in.
I think people are beginning to be more alarmed about it and I think alarm is
really useful.
There are people in the climate community who think,
you know,
it's,
it's dangerous to scare people,
it turns them off.
But I'm somebody who is awakened to this out of fear.
And when I look at the history of environmental activism,
when I look at activism generally like we don't try to get people to stop
smoking cigarettes by like messaging through optimism.
We try to get them to stop because we tell them how bad it's going to be for
them.
Drunk driving,
nuclear proliferation.
Same thing.
Rachel Carson wrote silent spring about pesticides.
It was called hyperbolic alarmist.
It led to the creation of the EPA and you know when you think about that UN
directive that we should be mobilizing at the scale of World War II to come back
climate.
We didn't fight World War II out of hope.
We fought world war two out of panic and I think that that should be part of how
we think about this story.
Obviously I think,
you know,
when I look around the world,
when I talk to anyone,
when I talked to my family,
when I watch TV,
when I watch to move,
whatever,
read stuff,
it just seems obvious to me that there are many more people who are still too
complacent about this issue.
Even if they're concerned about it a little bit.
Even if they're aware of it.
Um,
they don't think of it as like the overarching all encompassing story of our
time that requires an existential response.
And even saying those words make me uncomfortable because I like,
it's hard.
It's hard for me to believe that this is,
the threat is that big,
but that is what the science says.
Um,
and like I said before,
some of that science is not going to get born out,
but when you look at the full scope of it and just how,
just how large,
just how bleak the impacts will be,
you realize like,
we really need to wake up to just how dangerous a world we're heading into and
do everything we can to avoid it.
Um,
in addition to probably planning to adapt.